in our morning rounds more evidence
showing how sleep protects our health a
new study from the American Heart
Association finds sleeping less than six
hours a night could more than double the
risk of death for people with metabolic
syndrome that includes risk factors for
heart disease diabetes and Stroke our
dr. taryn Rula is a cardiologist at
northwell health good morning good
morning before we get to the sleep thing
real quick what exactly is metabolic
syndrome a lot of people don't know what
it is so it's essentially a cluster of
cardiovascular risk factors that raises
your cardiovascular risk if you have
three out of these five then you're
diagnosed with metabolic syndrome and
those things are elevated or enlarged
waist circumference a low HDL high
triglycerides high blood pressure and
high fasting blood sugar 30 to 40
percent of the American population has
metabolic syndrome in this study about
39% so very common so what's the
connection between the people that have
it and sleep well as Nora pointed out in
this study they found that people got
less than 6 hours we're not only an
increased risk of dying of
cardiovascular disease but we're an
increased risk of dying of more tat just
all causes of mortality you know there's
a lot of hypotheses as to why this might
be
we know that lack of sleep can change
brain areas like the hypothalamus and
hormone secretion to potentially
increase appetite can turn on your
sympathetic nervous system the
fight-or-flight which could raise your
blood pressure
it can change hormone secretion like
growth hormone and cortisol your stress
hormone that could cause imbalances in
your glucose metabolism and regulation
so there's there are mechanisms by which
whether you get X number of hours of
sleep
exactly exactly that's the thinking and
obviously the recommendation is about
seven to eight hours a night so the mean
average in this study was about six
hours they break the study broke new
ground on measuring sleep it did so for
most working in this area they asked
people how much did you sleep so it's
self-reported but in this study they put
them in a lab and they basically
measured how much sleep they were
getting in the laboratory research
setting so it's a little bit more
accurate obviously it was only one night
so you know we can't draw you know a lot
out of this one study but but they're
sleeping in their sleep I mean how do
you measure what's really good sleep in
what sleep is not that well what one of
the interesting things about this study
that they also did differently is that
they kind of factored out
what we call sleep disorder breathing or
things like obstructive sleep apnea
because we know that that race is
cardiovascular risk and so in most sleep
studies we don't really know was it the
sleep apnea
was it the sleep time but in this study
they kind of took that out of the
equation really focused on just the
duration of sleep and for the Nappers of
the world doesn't matter is hello my
name is Sarah Lee Road as it simply mean
the number about total hours you get in
a 24-hour period
eventually how much you get it one plea
it means the consistent number at night
and the napping isn't not really
included in that unfortunately gnarly
yeah but there's a take-home message for
everybody is I thought I was okay no
Nora hold him to your bosom rocking oh
yeah see that there yeah you're right I
need this yeah I feel better okay but
even if you don't have any of these risk
factors yes it was an issue is it not it
is so weak takeaway message for
everybody big takeaway message it needs
to be a priority we all sacrifice it for
social engagements for work we need to
make it a priority that's it how else do
we get other better sleep than making it
a priority well you have to practice
good sleep hygiene going to bed and
waking up at the same time every day
cool quiet darkroom
put away your devices yeah I guess all
right Thank You Vera good to see are you
feeling Gayle do you need a hug - yeah I
need your bosom - that's actually I do
think it's not very big fine person was
quite enough wasn't prancin enough yeah
that's okay I like to be loved the
intimacy